does intelligence
lead to happiness no
so so okay so back to the pill then
so why
uh when would you take the pill so you
said iq 80
90 100
110 you start going to the quartiles and
um is it obvious
isn't there
uh diminishing returns and then it
starts becoming negative
this is an empirical question
yes and so that i have uh advocated
in many forums
more research
on
enhancing the g factor
right now there's
there have been many claims about
enhancing intelligence
with you mentioned the n-back training
it was a big deal a few years ago it
doesn't work
data's very clear it does not work
you know or doing like memory tests like
training and so on yeah yeah it makes it
may give you a better memory in the
short run
but it doesn't impact your
g factor
it was very popular a couple of decades
ago that
the idea that listening to mozart
could make you more intelligent there
was a paper published on this with
somebody i knew published this paper
uh intelligence researchers never
believed it for a second
been hundreds of studies all the meta
analyses all the summaries and so on so
there's nothing to it
nothing to it at all
but but but wouldn't it be something
wouldn't it be
world
shaking
if you could take the normal
distribution of intelligence which we
haven't really talked about yet but
iq scores and the g factor is thought to
be a normal distribution
and shift it
to the right so that everybody
is smarter even a half a standard
deviation would be world shaking
because there are many social problems
many many social problems
that are exacerbated
by people with lower
ability to reason stuff out
and navigate everyday life
so i wonder if there's a threshold so
maybe
i would push back and say
universal shifting
of the
normal distribution may not be the
optimal way of shifting
maybe it's better to uh whatever the
asymmetric tank kind of distributions is
like really pushing the lower up
versus uh trying to make the
people at the average more intelligent
so you're saying that if in fact there
was some way to increase g let's just
call it metaphorically a pill an iq pill
we should only give it to people at the
lower end
no it's just intuitively
i i can see
that life becomes easier at the lower
end
if it's increased
it becomes less and less it is an
empirical scientific question but it
becomes less and less obvious to me that
more intelligence
is better
at the high end
it not because it would make life easier
but it would make
whatever problems you're working on
more solvable
and if you are working on artificial
intelligence there's a
tremendous potential
to good for for that to improve society
i understand
so
at that whatever problems you're working
on yes
but there's also the problem of the
human condition
there's
love there's fear and all those
beautiful things that sometimes if
you're good at
solving problems you're going to create
more problems for yourself it's uh i'm
not exactly sure so ignorance is bliss
is a thing so there might be a place
there might be a sweet spot of
intelligence
given your environment given your
personality all of those kinds of things
and that becomes less
beautifully complicated the more and
more intelligent
you become but that's a that's a that's
a question for literature not for
science perhaps
imagine this imagine there was an iq
pill yeah and it was developed by a
private company
and they are willing to sell it to you
and whatever price they put on it you
are willing to pay it because you would
like to be smarter yes but just before
they give you a pill
they give you a disclaimer form to sign
yes
don't hold us
that we you understand that this pill
has no guarantee that your life is going
to be better and in fact it could be
worse
well yes that's how lawyers work but i
would love for science to answer the
question
to try to predict if your life is going
to be better or worse
when you become more uh more or less
intelligent it's a it's a fascinating
question about what is the sweet spot
for the human condition
some of the things we see as
bugs might be
actually features may be crucial to our
overall happiness is our limitations
might lead to more happiness than less
but again more intelligence is better at
the lower end that's more that is that's
something that's less arguable and
and and fascinating if possible to
increase but you know there's virtually
no research
that's based on a neuroscience approach
to solving that problem
all the solutions that have been
proposed to solve that problem or to
ameliorate that problem are essentially
based on the blank slate assumption
that you know enriching the environment
removing barriers
all good things by the way i'm not
against any of those things
but there's no empirical evidence that
they're going to improve
the general reasoning ability
or make people more employable
have you read flowers of uh argandan yes
that's to the question of intelligence
and happiness
there are many profound aspects of that
story it was a film that was very good
uh if the film was called charlie for
the younger people who are listening to
this
uh
you might be able to stream it on
netflix or something but
it was a story about
uh a person with very low iq who
underwent a surgical procedure in the
brain and he slowly became a
genius and the tragedy of the story is
the effect was
temporary
it's a fascinating story really that
goes in contrast to the the basic human
experience that each of us individually
have but it raises the question of
the
the full
the full range of people you might be
able to be
given different levels of intelligence
you